there is a war there is an outright war
on every single one of us is you've got
that white girl there like
all light is so disturbing she's got her
finger in her mouth
the question that you ask is like is
this is this is this like why is it soft
porn what the hell is this
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
your brothers and sisters and dear
friends there is a war
there is an outright war on
every single one of us muslims are not
muslim
there is an outright war on the family
unit
and now the next target is our kids
brothers and sisters a lot of people are
doing reaction videos
about this i want to come at an angle
where it's so fundamentally connected to
our religion
our faith so much so that muslims and
non-muslims specific enormous is
watching this
we want you guys to understand as
muslims why we hold on so
tight to our values and as a reaver to
islam myself
seeing my own community going from one
stage to another
seeing my grandparents seeing how they
used to dress how they used to behave
how they used to act
to the second generation of how they
used to behave how they used to act
to the third generation and what it
follows
brothers and sisters this was one of the
main reasons i accepted islam because
what i
saw what i heard and how i felt
started to change me because i was
seeing the changes around me
what's going on today's time is brothers
and sisters we live in a
dysfunctional society where nobody knows
what is right what is wrong
every individual is talking about their
own rights
to um label their self as you know
whatever they want to label their self
as we live in a society
where it's come we think we know what
we're doing
but we are causing chaos we are shooting
ourselves on the feet
again and again and again in
the pursuit of finding
a truth a reality and this is what
happens
when a something like a human being
who is so fragile that a little this
like coronavirus can put us to our knees
we do not
submit and acknowledge our weaknesses
not by just a disease
but within our own self by reflecting
and saying hold in a second
do i know what's good for me and the
arrogance has led
us to say yes we do we know what's good
for us
and that has caused us to live in such a
society
that netflix and big corporations
and the elite and the giants can come
and control us and tell us what's right
hey we believe this is right
you know and we have organizations like
nike added us
big companies they don't give a damn
about your rights be you lgbqt whatever
you want to name be you a muslim be you
a jew
they don't care what makes money is what
they would promote
so don't come and say oh nike the mic is
only doing what it needs to do to make
money
if things change they would do the same
thing like from the mistake it was hugo
boss of our money he was making the same
clothes for hitler's
uh soldiers yeah so brothers and sisters
that is one thing we need to understand
and we're going to go to a
quran but before we do that we're going
to be reacting to this very
filthy disgusting video of what is about
to take over
our kids our future parents listen
carefully
because this very thing that we're going
to react to
one of the main actors is a muslim girl
if i'm not mistaken the very black girl
is a muslim and her parents if i'm not
mistaken have given the full right
for her to go and do this and she's a
muslim from a muslim background as far
as we know
the question that needs to be asked is
how does one's
parents the one who's brought you to
this life
raised you up throw you to the fire not
literally
but in this way what is was it the money
was it the fame
was it what you deemed to be success oh
look at my daughter she's in the cover
of
uh um new netflix 3 millions
10 million views amazing yes
you've become so corrupted that
money fame and the few likes you have
sold yourself to
let's go straight into it brother and
sister so i'm going to go first before i
react to the video
to the banner so this is the this is the
description of the movie
yeah it's called cuties can you imagine
cuties yeah
and the picture that they have you can
see on the screen sisters is
these young girls beats 9 10 11 how old
they are
in certain positions which one
wants to vomit i mean an 11 year old
girl
wearing hot pants in a specific position
that let's let's be real here where
majority
a lot of people watch pornography and
god knows what kind of things are going
through
their head when they're seeing girls in
hot pants 11 year old
in certain positions yeah we know what
certain individuals
will be thinking and because their minds
are polluted so this is what it says
amy 11 becomes fascinated with a
twerking dance crew she's now that was a
question question
fascinated intrigued i want to know
look at the words they're using
fascinated amy eleven fascinated
with with watched twerking twerking
dance which is fascinated
hoping to join them hoping
what is hope you know when you hope for
something you really want it i hope
i hope you know people say i hope i get
that i hope you get the job i hope you
have the house i hope you have the car
hope okay good she's hoping spanish what
i think to hope for
um she starts to explore
and these these words are very key do
you think netflix just randomly picks
these words
to explore yeah what's happening to
exploring yes panel all kinds of stuff
explore her femininity wow subhanallah
let's see how she's exploring her
femininity defying
her family's traditions you know
traditions are old traditions
from the old traditions old yeah she's
defying
so now let's go to the video brothers
and sisters in shortly let's gonna go to
the video
i mean one thing that's so flipping
disturbing
is you've got that white go there like
all light is so disturbing she's got her
finger in her mouth
the question that you ask is like is
this is this is this like where is the
soft
pawn what what the hell is this the
question that is
a specific angle a specific shot of
the girl in a seductive
gesture gesture with a finger
in her mouth
come on come on we've all seen movies
and we've seen
adults using their finger in their mouth
to you know insinuate something you know
anyways
ah they loved you how many likes did you
get
how many they liked you so what what's
the obsession with
the likes let's carry on
there you go now let's vilify the
religion
yeah apparently you know where's the
devil in
all the naked girls etc you know so just
just disregard what they're saying
disregard what your religion is saying
this regard it's old traditions she's
defying the family she's
defined the tradition she's going after
success what is true success
this twerk twerking uh joining the
twerking dance group
there you go and not only that show show
how
hard show how hard it like the way
they've made out a
practicing religious family of like you
know she's just like you know
slave labor and she's you know uh she's
getting beat up and she's carrying stuff
and it's all this kind of stuff
let's watch info i'm not gonna should
watch the whole thing
me
so what i'm going to do guys so now a
lot of people
have been outraged
now the reason why we're in the state
brothers and sisters is because
netflix brought made a poster for this
very film
and in that poster it was very
disturbing
now the thing is netflix is is confused
as the people because because we do not
have any objective morality
and everything is subjective and it's
all about because because this you see
the
islamic law has come down to protect the
rights of the people
their livelihood their wealth their akka
their mind their religion
yeah the the lineage of the family
islam has come to protect humanity as a
whole
communal so islam gives the right
to the community not to an individual
specific
person saying i would like to sell drugs
or
i want to drink alcohol i have fun by
drinking alcohol it makes me happy
hold on a second if what you're doing is
going to cause
greater heart to the community as a
whole you
can't do that because you're going to
cause bigger harm
to the wider community today's time that
we live in is what
the polar opposite
what an individual wants to do he should
do that
he needs to do that she needs to do that
however they feel they need to express
it
no lines so when there is no lines and
you're living your life in that manner
brothers and sisters
netflix is as confused as the people
because netflix is thinking
hold on a second what's the big deal
here
because why do we blame netflix no we
believe the community as a whole because
as a community
we have said yes to everything hey i
feel like a guitar be a guitar
i feel like a boy be a boy i feel like a
girl
you can be a girl gender neutral
flipping be neutral whenever you want to
put it into reverse or gear one
whenever you like except your discretion
whatever you want reverse gear first two
three four
five six wherever you want no problem
whatever you want
we've caused such confusion in our
society
that netflix when they bring up a poster
they're thinking
they're thinking there's nothing wrong
with this yeah and then the society
comes and says
oh no now we draw a red line and
especially in times where we live
where we have vile animals ex-muslims
who
in you can see the screen shot here who
believe that a father having sexual
intercourse with his own son
it's okay you know it's okay there's
nothing wrong with that
so where do you draw the line and this
is where the confusion arises
we're having a go at netflix how could
you do that as muslims
and we can say those who are religious
christians or jews we are consistent on
a certain thing
we don't say that's okay that's why we
say look this is wrong
we've never changed our position as
muslims we don't come and say hey that's
wrong
no no we've said there's a set of rules
and that is wrong
but today's society what do we have like
again i repeat again um that's wrong
that's okay oh that was wrong before now
it's okay
no that's changed now that's better now
pedophilia in certain countries
pedophilia is
yeah they they're trying to see as some
kind of before it was like a mental
illness
before homosexuality was the same it was
some kind of an illness what happened
today
it's a norm it's okay right and now the
same thing is happening with pedophilia
right it's okay you know it's dying to
be like oh it's just some you know some
kind of a
dysfunction in the brain or this or that
they're trying to find
and next thing you may know guys it
might be okay one day so don't blame
netflix
blame yourself because we've become a
dysfunctional society
because of this very reason and i'm
going to finish on this point
parents that are watching this if you
do not fix your act up and take the lead
because we are too engrossed as muslim
family members
in wealth money money chasing over and
over and we don't know what the
definition of success is
you are leaving your kids to danger
these things imagine your dues to seeing
this and thinking yeah i want to be like
them
we need to prioritize our time with our
kids what are they watching
who are their friends what kind of
circles are they in
because if you don't things are going to
get worse and what does allah subhanahu
wa tell us in the quran look at this
this is absolutely beautiful
and these are for parents who have
neglected muslims as well specifically
who have turned their back on their
religion allah says
in chapter 59 verse 19 be not be not
like those
who forgot allah and so he made them
forget their own souls those they are
the corrupt rebellious ones
look how allah says be not like those
who forgot allah
the remembrance of allah and so he made
them forget their own souls one lie this
is so deep look at the look at that
and by tabari this is they forgot
allah's rights
so allah made them forget their own
rights upon themselves subhanallah it's
mind-blowing look that is that they
forgot allah's rights
so allah made them forget their own
rights upon themselves
brahman says you have rights upon
yourself allah saying if you forget my
remembrance i will make you forget your
own rights upon yourself
so much so that your daughter will be
twerking you'll be okay with it like
this family who's allowed it muslim
family
no problem darling go you do it's
working it's fine you're gonna make it
the money whoo whatever it may be
yeah and then it says what is that one
said one
what can be greater tragic tragedy
tragedy than one forgetting oneself
one's moral rights upon oneself one
spiritual development
one's headlessness to the disease of the
heart to the extent that never does a
thought cross his mind about them
never does he consider not the
seriousness of the disease
but the disease itself what punishment
can be greater than the punishment of
one forgetting his own soul
his heart and his disease with no
thoughts of medicaid medication
or treatment completely oblivious of his
disease it's cures and the means of
attaining salvation in the everlasting
life that will follow
how sorrowful his affair is he is so
fearful of the destruction of his body
listen carefully
he is so fearful of the destruction of
his body what do we care about how's the
appearance
out everything is out on my nose my eyes
uh my backside
uh my fires my everything yeah see so
fearful of the destruction of his body
from whose destruction there is no
escape when you die but is forgetful of
the destruction of the soul
which is what he will carry on to the
next life
brothers and sisters nothing else needs
to be said
as society progresses to his failure and
do
brothers and sisters take care of your
family because you can see there's an
outright war on the family unit and now
they're coming after our kids
and i would like every family that's
watching this intro as well inshallah
please please it's your duty you
are the leaders fathers and mothers
take care of your kids before it's late
because allah will question you about
them
and if you think sending them to madrasa
and you at home
are not applying the principles of islam
and you're talking about women's rights
while you beat your wife
and your wife uh your sister you are
talking about this and that right but
you're
violating them and your children see
that you don't even pray salah
you don't even pray salah you don't you
don't give the rights of allah in your
house don't think sending your kids to
madras is going to change that because
they are going to look at
you till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh